Аава Айтлааті починає цей літній день досить незвично.
Її запросили до центру тестувань та вакцинації у фінській столиці Гельсінкі.
10-річна Аава бере участь у черговому етапі міжнародного дослідження
задля подолання пандемії COVID-19.
Нам потрібно більше інформації щодо цієї вакцини,
щоб діти теж могли отримувати щеплення.
Потрібно переконатися, що вона безпечна.
Аава - одна із кількох сотень фінських дітей віком до 12 років,
які беруть участь у дослідженні. Мета - перевірити, чи викликає вакцина
побічні дії та наскільки добре дитяча імунна система
справляється зі щепленням. Близько третини учасників
експерименту отримують укол плацебо.
Хоча деякі батьки досі сумніваються, чи робити щеплення своїм дітям,
мати Аави впевнена, що це єдиний вихід із пандемії.
Важливо випробувати вакцину на дітях.
Для боротьби з цим вірусом їм потрібні власні засоби захисту.
Я довіряю фінській владі. Вона почала випробування на дітях
лише після того, як було отримано достатньо інформації про безпеку вакцини.
Для цієї родини пандемія - це коли мати і батько
працюють вдома, у той час як діти нудяться.
Я не могла зустрічатися зі своїми друзями чи бабусями та дідусями.
Пандемія навчила мене бути більш терплячою.
Я дізналась, що іноді деякі заклади просто закриті
або що потрібно зачекати, доки ситуація покращиться.
Фінляндія - одна з чотирьох країн, де випробовують вакцину BioNTech-Pfizer для дітей.
Дослідники сподіваються, що безпечна вакцина допоможе запобігти рідкісним
серед дітей випадкам "ковіду" в важкій формі.
Такі довготривалі симптоми захворювання розвиваються
приблизно у чотирьох відсотків дітлахів.
Питання в тому, чи сприятиме вакцинація дітей
колективному імунітету. Чи потрібно робити щеплення дітям?
В ідеалі краще вакцинувати всіх, і тоді вірус
більше не циркулюватиме, і не буде з’являтися
нових варіантів. Тож я бачу явні переваги цього.
Водночас у багатьох країнах не вщухають дискусії щодо того,
наскільки доцільним є щеплення від "ковіду" дітей.
Дослідження на дітях - червона шмата не лише для антивакцинаторів.
У соцмережах багато людей висловлюють побоювання, що такі щеплення
не захистять від коронавірусу, а можуть довгостроково нашкодити здоров'ю дітей.
Один із аргументів противників щеплення для дітей - діти рідше хворіють на "ковід"
і мають здебільшого легкий перебіг.
Утім, як відомо, імунна система з віком працює менш ефективно.
Крім того, діти також нерідко мають хронічні захворювання
і належать до групи ризику. У Німеччині, приміром, 11 відсотків дівчат
та 16 відсотків хлопців віком до 17 років мають хронічні захворювання.
Водночас діти віком до 17 років, за оцінками ООН,
становлять майже третину світового населення. Тож коли йдеться
про набуття колективного імунітету та подолання пандемії у всьому світі,
без вакцинації цієї вікової групи не обійтися.
Наразі у різних країнах світу ситуація зі щепленням дітей від "ковіду" різна.
У Канаді та США вакцинація дітей віком від 12 до 15 років
вже йде повним ходом.  У Сполучених Штатах, приміром,
вже зробили щеплення від COVID-19 восьми мільйонам підлітків.
У ЄС наприкінці травня також дозволили використовувати
для щеплення цієї вікової групи вакцину BioNTech-Pfizer.
Щоправда, у Німеччині Постійна комісія зі щеплень радить
робити щеплення лише тим дітям і підліткам,
які страждають на хронічні захворювання.
Поширення нових варіантів коронавірусу змусило Ізраїль переглянути
свою попередню стратегію і почати вакцинацію дітей.
Я думаю, що зі зростанням рівня захворюваності в Ізраїлі,
зі збільшенням місцевих спалахів, зі штамом "Дельта",
який ми спостерігаємо зараз, потреба батьків у вакцинації своїх дітей
зростатиме. Отже, ми будемо бачити дедалі більше і більше щеплень.
У Китаї дозволили у надзвичайних випадках
щеплення дітей від 3 років вакциною Sinovac, яку застосовують і в Україні.
В Естонії підлітків планують почати вакцинувати з осені.
Іспанія провакцинує дітей від 12 до 17 років
за два тижні до початку нового навчального року.
Швидко прищепити усіх підлітків до кінця літа планує Австрія.
Дубай, Японія, Гонконг, Бразилія та інші так само дозволили
щеплення BioNTech-Pfizer дітям від 12 до 15.
У Польщі, де вже повністю вакцинована п'ята частина населення,
планують почати активну вакцинацію у школах з вересня.
У мене жодних занепокоєнь. Щепитися - природня річ і нема чого боятися.
Якщо я отримаю вакцину буде легше їхати на відпочинок.
Перших результатів дослідження з дітьми від шести місяців до одинадцяти років
BioNTech-Pfizer очікує у вересні.
За прищепленими малюками спостерігатимуть надалі
і після завершення дослідів. Таке ж дослідження проводить американська Moderna.
Дослідження векторних вакцин AstraZeneca та Johnson&Johnson
були призупинені або зупинені повністю після того,
як стали відомі рідкісні випадки тромбів.
Аава сподівається, що незабаром життя може нормалізуватися.
І у неї є один заклик до всіх.
Люди повинні продовжувати мити руки і дотримуватися
безпечної відстані. І нам потрібні вакцини для всіх.
Через півроку вона дізнається, чи вкололи
їй справжню вакцину, чи це просто плацебо.